Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans un nouveau podcast.
Avant de commencer, je voulais vous dire que j'ai lancé un membership YouTube.
Donc si vous voulez me soutenir, c'est 4 dollars par mois.
Ce n'est pas du tout obligatoire et je sais qu'on a tous déjà beaucoup
d'abonnements
et que dans le contexte actuel, vous n'avez pas forcément envie de dépenser
plus.
Mais si vous souhaitez me soutenir, c'est un moyen pour me soutenir dans la
création de ces vidéos.
Aujourd'hui, dans le podcast d'aujourd'hui, je voulais me poser la question,
enfin, réfléchir à la question.
Est-ce que c'est utile de prendre un cours avec un tuteur ?
Est-ce que c'est utile de prendre un cours avec moi par exemple, puisque je suis
professeur de français, tuteur de français.
La question, elle est intéressante pour moi parce que d'un côté, j'apprend le
japonais et le portugais en autodidacte, c'est-à-dire tout seul.
J'apprends ces deux langues et je suis assez convaincu, je suis même convaincu
qu'aujourd'hui,
avec grâce à Internet, grâce aux intelligences artificielles, on peut apprendre
n'importe quelle langue gratuitement.
On peut apprendre le chinois gratuitement et du coup, avec cette conviction, se
pose la question de
à quoi ça sert de prendre un cours avec un tuteur, d'autant plus que je donne
des cours de français.
Donc, finalement, la question, c'est est-ce que mon métier est utile ?
Est-ce que ce que je fais est utile ?
Et c'est d'autant plus intéressant pour moi que je suis vraiment intéressé par
l'apprentissage des langues
et du coup, je n'ai pas envie de faire quelque chose d'inutile.
Et donc aujourd'hui, dans ce podcast, j'avais envie de parler de ma vision de ce
que c'est un tuteur de langue, un professeur de langue,
les points positifs et les points négatifs, pardon, et aussi les pièges dans
lesquels il ne faut pas tomber,
les pièges à éviter pour les étudiants qui souhaitent apprendre une langue.
Donc, pour commencer, la première question, c'est, c'est quoi le rôle d'un
tuteur ?
Je regarde là parce que j'ai mon écran avec mes notes.
Le rôle d'un tuteur, c'est de vous aider à atteindre vos objectifs.
Donc, ça peut paraître bête dit comme ça, c'est un peu bateau,
mais quand vous prenez un cours de quelque chose, vous payez et vous espérez
avoir des connaissances ou apprendre quelque chose pendant ce cours.
C'est exactement pareil avec les cours de langue.
Grosso modo, quand on va prendre un cours de langue, on a envie de s'améliorer.
Dans l'apprentissage des langues, il y a plusieurs aspects.
Il y a l'immersion, il y a l'expression, donc l'écoute, la lecture, parler et
lire et écrire, pardon, je vais y arriver.
Et donc, ça, c'est différentes choses sur lesquelles on peut travailler.
C'est différents aspects d'un apprentissage d'une langue.
C'est un peu comme dans les jeux vidéo où vous avez des caractéristiques.
Et c'est un peu comme si quand on apprend une langue, on essaye de développer un
peu chacune de ces caractéristiques.
Bien sûr, tout va ensemble, quand on apprend, on apprend tout ensemble.
Mais parfois, la phrase typique, c'est "je comprends, mais je n'arrive pas à
parler".
Souvent, on commence avec l'immersion, souvent moi-même, je recommande de
commencer avec l'immersion.
Donc, on augmente ces caractéristiques, entre guillemets.
Et après, il y a le moment où on essaye de passer à l'expression,
où là, il faut travailler les deux autres caractéristiques, l'écriture et le
parler, enfin parler la langue.
Donc ça, un tuteur, finalement, il va vous aider à atteindre vos objectifs.
Selon, un peu ces caractéristiques, selon ces niveaux, ces compétences
dans la langue que vous essayez de développer.
Un tuteur, c'est quelqu'un qui a des connaissances linguistiques.
La linguistique, c'est la connaissance de la langue.
Ça, ça peut paraître bête, surtout quand on parle un natif,
mais je pense que c'est quelque chose d'intéressant et c'est quelque chose que
j'ai appris avec l'expérience.
Pour la simple et bonne raison qu'aujourd'hui encore, ça m'arrive, qu'un
étudiant me pose une question.
Pourquoi vous dites ça comme ça en français ?
Et que j'ai un petit blanc de quelques secondes, j'ai un petit blanc et je me
dis "bah, je sais pas".
Ça me semble juste naturel.
Et en fait, les natifs, on a un apprentissage naturel de la langue.
Du coup, dans la majorité des cas, on parle sans connaître aucune règle.
Un tuteur, il a des connaissances linguistiques, c'est-à-dire qu'il va connaître
les conjugaisons, ce genre de choses.
Il a une connaissance théorique de la langue qui n'est pas le cas de tous les
natifs.
Ce n'est pas le cas de tous les natifs parce qu'on n'a pas besoin d'avoir cette
théorie, cette connaissance théorique,
ou du moins on l'a appris à l'école, mais en l'utilisant, on n'y pense plus,
donc on a complètement oublié.
Et du coup, quand on parle, on ne se rend même pas compte des règles qu'on
utilise.
Ça, ces connaissances, elles sont importantes pour pouvoir expliquer aux
étudiants les règles qu'on utilise.
Un exemple, c'est "il faut que j'aille au supermarché".
Pourquoi on dit "il faut que j'aille".
Ça, en fait, c'est le subjonctif présent, etc., etc.
Donc ça, un tuteur, il a ce rôle aussi d'avoir un peu ces connaissances,
c'est de pouvoir vous expliquer quand vous avez des questions là-dessus.
Après, si vous posez la question et que le tuteur n'a pas la réponse tout de
suite,
mais qu'il vérifie les informations pour vous les donner, ce n'est pas grave.
Je me défends parce que j'ai fait ça plusieurs fois.
Il vaut mieux réfléchir et dire, je ne suis pas sûr de l'information,
je vais la vérifier et je vais te la donner,
plutôt que de donner une mauvaise information en tant que tuteur.
Et à ça, il y a aussi la capacité à évaluer votre niveau,
la capacité à évaluer votre niveau et aussi à avoir du recul sur la langue.
C'est important de savoir évaluer le niveau d'un étudiant,
parce que si vous ne savez pas parler au présent,
on ne va pas vous faire travailler le passé ou le futur.
Il y a un ordre dans lequel progresser pour que ce soit un peu naturel.
Et donc avoir cette capacité à évaluer le niveau de langue de l'étudiant,
ça permet un peu de prioriser l'apprentissage qu'il faut faire.
Avoir du recul sur la langue, c'est pareil, c'est savoir aussi ce qui est
prioritaire.
Parce que parfois, il y a des choses, la grammaire française, la théorie, c'est
infinie.
Vous pouvez chercher des choses à l'infini et vous allez toujours apprendre des
choses.
Mais finalement, le plus important, c'est de prioriser ce qui est vraiment
important.
Ça, c'est avoir du recul sur la langue et comprendre comment les natifs
utilisent la langue.
Par exemple, l'exemple que je donne souvent, c'est que dans les livres de
grammaire française,
souvent, les premières questions qu'on vous montre, c'est des questions avec le
sujet verbe inversé.
Et ça, j'avoue, c'est mon opinion, mais j'ai un peu du mal à comprendre pourquoi
on fait ça,
alors que quand on parle français dans la vie de tous les jours,
on n'utilise quasiment jamais ce système d'inversion sujet verbe.
Et ça, un tuteur, normalement, il doit avoir un peu cette vision sur ce qui est
utilisé
et ce qui est vraiment utile, parce que si je vous apprends l'inversion sujet
verbe
et que dans la vie de tous les jours, tout le monde pose des questions en
utilisant,
est-ce que, ou juste en montant l'intonation à la fin, vous allez être un peu
perdu.
Donc ça, il faut savoir un peu prioriser les choses.
Et enfin, c'est quoi le rôle du tuteur pour finir avec cette question ?
Le point le plus important, selon moi, c'est d'expression orale.
Quand je parlais des compétences, vous pouvez quasiment travailler toutes les
compétences tout seuls.
Vous n'avez pas besoin d'un tuteur.
Le tuteur, sa vraie valeur ajoutée, c'est l'expression orale,
c'est qu'il va vous faire parler et il va s'adapter à votre niveau
pour essayer de vous faire progresser le plus possible.
Donc c'est mon opinion aussi.
Il y a des personnes qui ont besoin de prendre un cours avec un tuteur
pour apprendre de la grammaire, etc.
Et c'est très bien.
Mais mon opinion, c'est que là où vous pouvez maximiser,
oui, c'est ça, la valeur d'un cours, entre guillemets, c'est avec l'expression
orale.
C'est que vous arrivez au cours et vous parlez le plus possible.
Le tuteur, lui, il essaye de vous diriger un peu sur des choses.
S'il voit qu'il y a des points à apprendre, à revoir,
il vous fait une petite révision rapide sur un point spécifique.
Mais voilà, ça, c'est pour moi le rôle d'un tuteur, c'est tous ces points-là.
C'est vraiment un peu du coaching.
Le tuteur, il n'a plus le rôle de celui qui a l'information,
celui qui a le savoir, comme je ne sais pas en quelle année, en Grèce antique.
Mais avant, le professeur, c'est celui qui avait les livres,
qui avait les connaissances et qui donnait les connaissances aux élèves.
Maintenant, les connaissances sont accessibles partout gratuitement.
Donc, le tuteur, lui, il a un rôle de coach.
Et donc, ça, pour ça, selon moi, c'est le rôle d'un tuteur
et ça va nous permettre de répondre à est-ce que c'est utile, finalement,
de prendre une classe, de prendre un cours, de réserver un cours avec un tuteur.
Mais comment trouver un bon tuteur pour apprendre le français ?
C'est l'occasion pour moi de vous parler du sponsor de cette vidéo, Italki.
Je ne recommande que les outils et services que je trouve sincèrement utiles.
Pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas Italki,
il s'agit d'une plateforme en ligne d'apprentissage des langues personnalisées
qui vous permet de trouver des professeurs natifs
dans plus de 150 langues, y compris le français,
et de réserver des cours particuliers et personnalisés.
C'est le meilleur moyen de s'immerger
dans une grande variété de langues et de cultures sans vivre à l'étranger.
Vous pouvez trouver des tuteurs des différents pays francophones
et filtrer les résultats selon leurs spécialités, leurs prix ou vos centres
d'intérêt.
Et surtout, vous pouvez choisir le type de cours en fonction de vos objectifs.
Que vous souhaitez améliorer vos compétences d'écoute et d'expression orale
ou apprendre à tenir une conversation.
Vous trouverez toujours un professeur adapté à vos besoins.
C'est entièrement personnalisé.
C'est efficace parce que vous recevez des feedbacks et des conseils en temps
réel
de la part d'experts linguistiques.
Les enseignants sont encourageants et créent un espace stimulant
où ils vous aident à gagner en confiance,
à être moins frustrés et à constater vos progrès.
J'ai d'ailleurs pu échanger avec un tuteur Italki.
but most of the time it is at the
Mais la plupart du temps, c'est au feeling, c'est-à-dire que je vais voir
feeling that is, I will see
as the conversation progresses
au fil de la conversation ce qui peut intéresser l'élève et ce qui ne va pas
what can interest
the student and what will not interest him I see
l'intéresser.
Si je parle d'un sujet et que je vois que ses yeux s'illuminent,
uh if I talk about a subject
and I see that his eyes light up
I'll tell myself
je vais me dire "Tiens, ça, ça l'intéresse, on peut approfondir ce sujet-là."
he's interested, can we go deeper on
this subject
on the contrary if I see that there is a subject in which
Au contraire, si je vois qu'il y a un sujet dans lequel l'élève ne parle pas
uh the student doesn't talk too much bah
trop,
I'll tend to avoid it
je vais avoir tendance à l'éviter.
Pendant cet échange, Nicolas m'a expliqué comment il personnalise chacun de ses
cours
pour aider du mieux possible ses étudiants.
L'un des principaux avantages d'Italki est que vous payez seulement pour chaque
cours que vous faites.
Il n'y a pas d'abonnement, les cours s'adaptent donc entièrement à votre budget
et à votre emploi du temps.
Vous pouvez commencer à tout moment sans aucune pression.
Donc si vous voulez commencer à développer des automatismes et améliorer votre
français conversationnel,
cliquez sur le lien dans la description pour commencer dès maintenant votre
apprentissage.
En utilisant mon code promo exclusif "FELIX5" pour tout achat de 10 dollars ou
plus de crédit,
vous bénéficierez d'une réduction de 5 dollars sur votre premier cours.
Ce code est valable uniquement pour les 50 premières personnes, alors
profitez-en vite.
J'ai également laissé un lien vers le profil de Nicolas dans la description.
N'hésitez pas à réserver un cours avec lui.
Merci à Italki de soutenir mon travail.
Si je reprends le sujet de l'expression orale, il existe des alternatives pour
pratiquer gratuitement.
Par exemple avec des applications comme HelloTalk ou d'autres sites de ce genre
qui permettent de faire des échanges linguistiques.
Le truc, c'est que le vrai point positif d'un tuteur, c'est que c'est entièrement
personnalisé et il s'adapte entièrement à votre niveau.
Selon en plus avec, grâce à son expérience, pardon.
Quand on fait des échanges linguistiques, c'est assez difficile de trouver
quelqu'un qui a exactement le même niveau que nous.
Parce que quand c'est un peu déséquilibré, quand on tombe sur quelqu'un qui
parle très bien et que nous on ne parle pas très bien,
très rapidement, l'échange n'est plus très fluide.
Et également, c'est quasiment impossible, enfin c'est quasiment impossible.
C'est difficile de trouver quelqu'un avec des connaissances linguistiques.
L'idéal, c'est d'avoir un professeur avec qui faire ça parce que la personne va
pouvoir vous aider sur les différentes choses à améliorer, à travailler.
Alors que quand vous faites ça avec quelqu'un que vous rencontrez sur un site,
forcément c'est beaucoup moins efficace parce que la personne va moins bien
analyser, j'ai envie de dire, vos qualités et vos faiblesses.
Moins bien analyser, c'est que un tuteur, il a l'habitude, il a l'expérience de
faire ça et du coup il va pouvoir vous dire,
"Travaille plus ce point-là, travaille plus ça", etc.
Et donc ça c'est vraiment le point positif, je trouve, d'un tuteur, c'est que
c'est entièrement personnalisé, il a de l'expérience et ça c'est idéal pour
progresser.
Si je prends un exemple, quand j'étais au Japon, donc je pense que quand je suis
allé au Japon, j'avais peut-être un niveau A2 B1 pendant un an et j'ai eu
plusieurs cas de figure.
Un jour j'ai dû aller à la banque pour ouvrir un compte en banque pour pouvoir
travailler.
Je suis arrivé au comptoir avec la personne qui a pris mon dossier pour me créer
un compte en banque et c'était impossible.
En fait, elle me parlait en japonais très rapidement et je ne comprenais pas
tout, donc je lui disais "Est-ce que vous pouvez répéter plus lentement s'il
vous plaît ?"
Elle répétait exactement la même chose à la même vitesse.
Et du coup je ne comprenais pas plus, j'étais là, bon, j'ai pas compris la
première fois, vraiment il aurait fallu à un sacré coup de chance pour
comprendre la deuxième.
Et à l'inverse, une fois, enfin, on a travaillé dans des fermes au Japon et on
est arrivé chez un couple et la dame, ils avaient l'habitude d'accueillir plein
d'étrangers.
Toutes les semaines, tous les mois, il y avait des nouvelles personnes et la
dame en fait, elle avait, je pense qu'elle avait développé un peu ce sens
pédagogique.
Mais c'est-à-dire que quand on essayait de parler en japonais, déjà elle nous
répondait en japonais, déjà elle était contente de nous aider à apprendre le
japonais.
Alors que parfois on essayait de parler en japonais, on nous répondait en
anglais.
Donc déjà elle prenait le temps de nous répondre en japonais, mais surtout, elle
savait s'adapter à notre niveau.
S'il y avait quelque chose qu'on ne comprenait pas, elle répétait plus lentement
et elle reformulait et elle utilisait d'autres mots.
Et ça, c'est une compétence qui est hyper intéressante quand vous voulez
pratiquer l'expression orale, parce que ça vous permet d'avoir le sentiment
d'une conversation fluide, alors que la personne en fait s'adapte à votre
niveau.
Et ça, je trouve que c'est une capacité d'un tuteur qui est hyper intéressante.
Parce qu'en fait, quand vous allez parler avec un natif, s'il ne comprend pas ou
si vous ne comprenez pas ce qu'il dit, il va vous regarder en mode "mh", il va
répéter la même phrase et vous allez être en mode "mh", toujours pas.
Il y a des personnes qui ne sont pas des tuteurs qui ont cette compétence.
Je ne dis pas que les tuteurs sont les seules personnes à savoir faire ça, mais
je trouve que c'est vraiment une des qualités primordiales pour un tuteur.
C'est que si l'étudiant, je prends mon exemple, si je pose une question et que
l'étudiant n'a pas compris, je vais essayer de répéter plus lentement et
d'utiliser d'autres mots pour essayer de débloquer en fait la conversation.
Et ça, en fait, quand on fait ça, ça rend tout de suite la discussion beaucoup
plus fluide et ça met l'étudiant un peu en confiance, quoi, parce que si, enfin,
quand je suis allé à la banque là, ouvrir mon compte bancaire au Japon, je suis
arrivé, elle m'a, comme on dit en français, elle m'a enchaîné, j'ai rien
compris.
Et je suis ressortie, mais je me suis dit, mais je suis une pauvre merde, je
suis une grosse merde en japonais, mon japonais, désolé pour mon français, mon
japonais est vraiment merdique, ça fait trois ans que j'apprends et tout ça pour
ça, alors que quand on travaillait à la ferme, on avait des discussions à table,
parce que quand, dès que ça bloquait un petit peu, elle reformulait, elle
parlait plus lentement et ça, c'était hyper encourageant.
Et ça, c'est vraiment le point positif de prendre un cours avec un tuteur, c'est
que c'est quelqu'un qui a cette compétence et qui va être entièrement dédié à
vous, vous payez une heure et du coup, la personne est là pour une heure,
essayer de vous faire parler le plus possible.
Si votre objectif, c'est de parler, si votre objectif, c'est d'apprendre de la
grammaire, le cours sera sûrement différent, mais dans le cadre d'un cours
conversationnel, c'est hyper bénéfique, je pense, ce genre de cours.
Et en plus, c'est entièrement personnalisé, pour ma part, au début quand je
manquais d'expérience, j'essayais d'arriver à des cours en préparant des
sujets, tiens, aujourd'hui on va parler de l'écologie, on va parler de la
politique, ce genre de choses, et en fait très rapidement, j'ai remarqué que
certains élèves étaient intéressés par certains sujets et d'autres par d'autres
sujets.
Donc en général, j'ai plus tendance à improviser mes questions, selon les
élèves, pour essayer de m'adapter le plus possible au sujet qu'ils apprécient,
parce que plusieurs fois, ça m'est arrivé avec plusieurs élèves, mais parfois
sur un sujet, la personne, je vois très bien qu'elle n'a pas envie de parler, et
dès qu'on passe sur un sujet qui la passionne, là, c'est vraiment, elle a envie.
Et en fait, je sais pas comment dire ça, mais quand vous n'avez pas envie de
parler d'un sujet, vous allez vite utiliser l'excuse de "mais non, je ne suis
pas assez bon dans la langue que je parle, je ne suis pas assez bon en français
pour parler sur ce sujet", alors que si c'est quelque chose qui vous passionne
et que vous avez vraiment envie de le partager, là, vous allez trouver tous les
moyens possibles pour exprimer les idées que vous avez.
Et ça, je trouve que c'est hyper important d'être dans cette démarche, et du
coup, pour moi, c'est le cadre idéal pour travailler son expression orale,
c'est-à-dire que vous allez avoir quelqu'un qui s'adapte entièrement à vous et
qui va débloquer toutes les situations qui peuvent être bloquantes, et
idéalement, vous allez parler d'un sujet qui vous intéresse vraiment, donc tout
est entièrement personnalisé et c'est idéal pour progresser.
Maintenant, le prix négatif, oh, le prix négatif, j'ai fait un lapsus, le point
négatif, c'est le prix, tout simplement parce que quand vous payez un cours
individuel, vous payez le salaire de la personne du tuteur pendant une heure, et
quand, enfin, en France, il y a beaucoup de taxes, par exemple, moi, je dois
payer quelque chose comme environ 25% de taxes avant les impôts.
Donc, quand je travaille une heure, il faut que mon prix soit bien sûr plus
élevé pour pouvoir gagner ma vie correctement avec ça.
Je suis en train de me justifier sur mes prix, j'ai fini dans deux minutes.
En plus de ça, il y a le nombre d'heures de travail, c'est-à-dire que,
forcément, pendant un cours, je vais parler en anglais, je vais parler en
français, je vais beaucoup parler, et donc, quand je fais 8 heures de cours par
jour, la fin, je suis complètement épuisé.
Et en plus de ça, il y a la préparation, donc préparer un cours, selon les
étudiants, ça peut être plus ou moins préparé en amont, et ça, c'est pareil, ça
demande du travail supplémentaire.
Et donc, tout ça pour dire que, pour un tuteur de langue, c'est difficile de
faire 40 heures par semaine.
Moi, je fais environ 20 25 heures, parce que je sais que, déjà, j'ai envie de
travailler sur le contenu, j'ai envie de développer d'autres choses, mais aussi
que, en fait, si je fais que ça toute la journée, au bout d'un moment, je vais
être fatigué et je vais être moins disponible pour les élèves.
Et du coup, ça, ça implique de forcément devoir avoir un prix un peu plus élevé.
C'est la raison pour laquelle les prix des tuteurs sont plus élevés que
n'importe quel autre méthode.
C'est plus cher, tout simplement, parce que c'est entièrement individuel.
Ça, c'est le point négatif, selon moi, parce que, comme je le disais au début,
théoriquement, enfin, non, c'est même pas théoriquement, dans la réalité, vous
pouvez apprendre n'importe quelle langue sans dépenser le moindre argent.
Ça, c'est une réalité.
Du coup, le prix ici, c'est vraiment l'aspect négatif, parce que ça va vous
coûter cher.
Donc, après, bien évidemment, il y a une dimension pouvoir d'achat.
Est-ce que vous avez les moyens de payer des cours ?
Et si vous avez les moyens, prenez des cours tous les jours, si ça ne vous
dérange pas.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'au moment de prendre des cours, si c'est une
question un peu de budget pour vous, posez-vous la bonne question de qu'est-ce
que vous voulez faire pendant ce cours.
Et là, j'arrive un peu sur le piège à éviter.
C'est que je pense qu'on peut facilement tomber dans le...
C'est bon, je prends un ou deux cours par semaine, je suis en train d'apprendre
le français.
Et ça, c'est un peu le piège à éviter, parce que c'est sûr que si vous vous
reposez uniquement sur vos cours, ça ne va pas être 100% bénéfique.
Ce que j'essaie d'encourager les élèves à faire, c'est de les pousser au maximum
sur l'immersion, en même temps qu'on fait les cours.
Si, pendant une semaine, vous prenez un ou deux cours par semaine ou plus,
l'idée, c'est toujours à côté de faire un maximum d'immersion.
Et en fait, si vous faites tout ce travail d'immersion, c'est là où les cours
vont être d'autant plus bénéfiques, parce que vous allez vraiment voir la
progression.
Pendant les cours, vous allez pratiquer des choses que vous avez vues pendant
l'immersion, ça va vous faire mémoriser plus rapidement.
Et en fait, c'est un cercle vertueux.
Alors que si vous vous dites, non mais c'est bon, je fais une heure ou deux de
français par semaine, je vais progresser.
Là, c'est le piège, parce que vous allez faire un an de cours et au bout de
cette année, vous n'aurez pas beaucoup progressé.
En un an, on peut voir les règles de grammaire basique, le présent, le passé, le
futur, les articles, ce genre de choses.
Mais votre cerveau, il va être trop peu exposé à la langue.
Il a besoin d'être exposé à la langue pour vraiment que tout se mette en ordre.
Et les cours, ils vont être vraiment bénéfiques si vous faites ce travail à
côté.
Et donc ça, c'est vraiment le piège à éviter, c'est de ne pas travailler à côté
des cours.
Ça rejoint un peu le côté négatif parce que quand vous vous dites, j'ai passé un
an à payer des cours toutes les semaines,
un ou deux cours par semaine, vous allez vous dire, je n'ai pas beaucoup appris
comparé aux prix que j'ai dépensé.
Mais je pense que vraiment, la valeur du cours, elle va prendre, elle va
augmenter si vous travaillez à côté.
Ça peut paraître bête, mais je pense que c'est vraiment ce truc de faire un peu
tous les jours et que si vous ne le faites pas, finalement, ça va être moins
efficace.
Donc voilà, désolé si c'était un peu brouillon.
Comme d'habitude, c'est un podcast fait pour vous faire travailler votre
immersion.
J'essaye de trouver des sujets qui peuvent être intéressants pour vous.
C'est pour ça qu'ici, on parle de est-ce que c'est utile d'avoir un tuteur.
Pour résumer, je pense que c'est utile.
Forcément, ça coûte plus cher que d'autres méthodes.
Et du coup, si ça coûte cher, il faut se poser la question, pourquoi est-ce que
je veux prendre des cours.
Et quand vous vous posez cette question, tout de suite, vous allez arriver au
cours avec une démarche plus intéressante qui va être de comment je peux
maximiser mon apprentissage pendant cette heure de cours que j'ai payée.
Et ça, c'est hyper intéressant parce que si vous ne le faites pas, alors ce sera
moins efficace et le prix sera cher pour des résultats moindres.
Donc si vous voulez maximiser la valeur de vos cours, préparez bien, travaillez
à côté et là, ça sera vraiment utile.
Le dernier point un peu bonus, j'ai noté ça, échange culturel et je pense que
c'est aussi une bonne chose, c'est que vous avez en face de vous un natif qui
vit dans le pays, qui connaît le pays.
Et c'est l'occasion aussi d'échanger et de poser un maximum de questions au
tuteur sur le pays, sur sa culture.
Et ça, c'est pareil, c'est entièrement personnalisé donc si vous avez envie de discuter de certains sujets,
le tuteur s'adaptera
toujours entièrement à vos demandes et ça, c'est très bénéfique.
Voilà, j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu.
Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à laisser un like, un commentaire et voilà pour
me dire si vous avez aimé ou pas.
Et on se retrouve pour un prochain podcast.
Le prochain podcast, ce sera sûrement une discussion avec mon beau frère.
Donc voilà, merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout et je vous dis à la prochaine.